genzyme a ses habitués depuis 40 ans
l'idée robert s'y rendent jusqu'à
plusieurs fois par semaine bien qu'il
n'y ait aucune famille en voisin
bienveillant il y réalise de petits
travaux d'entretien et s'assure que
personne ne vienne troubler le repos des
défunts une histoire qui commence en
1979 presque par hasard
lise nouvellement installés dans la rue
croise une amie au portail du cimetière
elle me dit passmore ce tuto que fais tu
là et alors c'est à ce moment là qu'elle
m'a dit tiens tu pourrais prendre les
clés de ce cimetière par problème et au
printemps elle est venue me voir et elle
a dit pourri aussi entretenir et c'est
ce qu'on a accepté sans réfléchir
vraiment de bon coeur et nous l'avons
fait pendant 40 ans si au début 19e
siècle wintzenheim compter la plus
grande communauté juive du département
aujourd'hui il n'y reste que deux
familles autrefois rural le judaïsme
s'est déplacé vers les villes ainsi
nombre de cimetières historique se
retrouve son gardien pour l'étendard
venir en aide à la communauté était une
évidence
mon mari et moi on est des enfants des
héros du silence
nos deux parents étaient des résistants
mon mari a été orphelin à l'âge de deux
ans son père a été arrêté par la gestapo
donc c'était déjà la rhune raison on
était attaché à beaucoup de choses
robert ayant vécu cette enfance
difficile comme les enfants juifs et
après il ya eu une grande amitié avec
des enfants juifs laventure bénévoles
dure depuis quatre décennies quand
monsieur et madame tornare reçoivent le
titre le payeur de mémoire ils font
partie depuis cet automne des 22 haut
rhinois chargé de veiller sur les
cimetières juifs des partenaires nous
avons dans le département veine de
cimetières dont une grande majorité où
il n'y a plus de communauté et donc pour
éviter des problèmes en tout genre dans
les cimetières
le département a proposé de créer cet
organisme de veilleurs de mémoire ont
connu par le département et
donc c'est l'élaboration de tout ce
système qu'on a mis en place une
douzaine de cimetières ont trouvé leur
meilleur
le consistoire et le conseil
départemental sont toujours à la
recherche de bénévoles